also i invite you to join the discussion
on the david pakman show subreddit
nearly
30 000 if you can imagine nearly 30 000
of our viewers and listeners
are now subscribed to the david pakman
show subreddit
you can find it at davidpakman.com
reddit a few interesting posts i spotted
this morning
one asks why do trumpus need to believe
that antifa was behind the january 6th
insurrection
hear me out says this user let's imagine
the insane world that the trumpists live
in is reality the election was stolen
from trump and there was rampant fraud
in favor of joe biden it was rigged at
every level
and joe biden is a little illegitimate
president if this is the case then don't
trump supporters have the moral
obligation to take back their country
and reinstall trump as president
since he was rightly elected after all
the declaration of independence says the
people have a right to
alter or abolish an illegitimate
government going on to say my point is
this
under the premise that the election was
truly stolen
then they shouldn't need to blame antifa
for the riots since the people at the
capitol
should have gone even farther in their
actions to prevent biden from becoming
president in other words
none of the trumpist republicans should
be condemning the insurrectionists or
blaming antifa
they should be embracing their actions
of the the actions of the
insurrectionists instead
this is a very important point and this
is something that we've been talking
about for a long time which is
very often these radical conspiratorial
hypotheses from the right conflict
and this is this is the epitome of that
on the one hand you have people who for
two months
following the lead of trump and rudy
giuliani and all these other people
believed the election was really stolen
joe biden didn't really win donald trump
actually won
if that actually is true then of course
they would go to the capitol on january
6th
and again they went because they did
believe that that was true
so then why would they be blaming antifa
they really would be there
as people demanding that the rightful
winner of the presidential election be
installed
it would be trumpists that would go you
wouldn't need to point the finger at
antifa are we meant to believe now
that they really believe the election
was stolen and they were willing to do
whatever it took
just like donald trump said you've got
to fight for it just like rudy said
trial by
combat or whatever it was but then they
didn't actually go on january 6th they
stayed home
even though they were ready and willing
to fight for their president no
it's incoherent and this is very
accurately pointing it out
another interesting post from the
subreddit argues
that good republicans don't exist um
this user says
there is no rot within the republican
party the republican party
is the rod right down to its moldy core
everything republicans stand for is
wrong politically they stand for tax
cuts for the rich
de-unionization sucking off the
military-industrial complex
trickle-down economics and brown people
are bad ideologically they stand for
lgbtq is bad women's rights is bad
more votes bad brown people bad again
living wages are socialism
affordable health care socialism
fighting climate changes socialism on
and on and they go on to say tell me
honestly
what actual honest to
bat christ good comes from the continued
existence of the republican party what's
a single genuinely good thing they do
for the american people
and not just the one percent the
wealthiest one percent of their base
and um to to a great degree this is true
and uh what i mean by that is there are
people
who i disagree with politically
uh but who i don't think are out of
their mind
bad people necessarily in the republican
party
moderate republicans whose priorities
are uh they
are socially i don't want to say
socially liberal
but socially libertarian let's say um
and really genuinely believe that you
know regulation's not
socialism but that the country is better
off with less
regulation and lower taxes and whatever
okay i mean these these are political
disagreements
as sold as uh as old as as government
itself
uh but to a great degree this is
accurate where you have essentially the
worst instincts
of just bad people coalesced around
um really horrible leaders donald trump
being the the sort of greatest example
of that
and they make a lot of good points as i
think the point i would make
join the discussion at davidpakman.com
reddit